what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so a lot of you guys seem to be
really really receptive to the question
of where are the Watchmen in DC rebirth
it was really more like a speculation
video where we just kind of theorized
where the Watchmen were what they were
doing why dr. Manhattan presumably did
the kind of things that he did if mr. Oz
was mr. Oz it was awesome and yes or if
he was like classic Lex Luthor it was a
really cool video and you guys really
seemed to enjoy it so in this video
we're going to try our best to answer
the question where is Shazam in DC
rebirth so for those of you guys who are
new and are just really looking for a
simple answer the short answer is that
Shazam has only been featured in one
comic so far and that was in Hellblazer
rebirth and it was literally the
circumstance where John Constantine
returned in New York some things were
popping off with mysticism Wonder Woman
considered intervening ashes in what he
thought and he was like well I mean I
guess we could but ultimately they ended
up just staying hands off unless things
got really bad otherwise we're just
going to let Constantine do whatever it
was that he was going to do and that was
it that was really all there was in
terms of Shazam's appearances in DC
rebirth that's the only story he showed
up is now the long answer is that DC is
actually playing a pretty cool game with
him when it comes to Shazam for those of
us who were new Shazam was basically a
spin-off of Superman that's really what
he was going all the way back to like
the 1930s when Superman first showed up
Bill Parker and CeCe back worked for a
company called Fawcett publications and
Boston publications launched a comic
book arm called Fawcett comics and the
head of Fawcett comics literally went to
them and said give me Superman without
Superman and the result was that they
came up with Billy Batson this kid who
was endowed with the powers of various
gods he would shout the word Shazam and
he would end up becoming like an adult
Superman more or less now of course the
funny thing about this was that Shazam
actually outsold Superman by a pretty
huge margin because kids could read his
stories and they were like yeah like all
I have to do is say Shazam and I
basically become Superman
the result was that DC sued Fawcett
publications and ended up in a lawsuit
that lasted like ten years and then
eventually Fawcett went bankrupt DC got
the rights and they kept him on the back
burner for something like 20 years or
something long those lines but in terms
of the new 52
Shazam at least that iteration was not
the most well received people liked him
but he wasn't like classic Shazam which
is to say the version of the character
that we saw which
we 1985 with crisis on Infinite Earths
in 2011 when DC rebooted but the idea
here was that following or really coming
to the tail end of the new 52 branding
so to speak going into DC rebirth DC
wrote a story called darkside war and
what darkside war was designed to do was
basically shuffle up the landscape and
it was really an excuse for them to be
able to launch DC rebirth in the first
place and so while there were a lot of
different things that went on with
regards to different career different
characters gaining new powers and so on
and so forth Shazam was really had his
powers kind of modified so to speak
historically speaking
Shazam always gained his abilities
because they were basically lent to him
in the same capacity that Wonder Woman's
powers are lent to her Shazam can tap
into these various abilities that grant
him super speed super strength will
enhance durability and so on and so
forth basically making him Superman the
idea here was that with Darkseid war
what DC did is they came back and said
that's actually not the case instead
what happened was that when Shazam
originally got his powers or at least
when he got his powers during the new 52
what it basically happened is that he
was literally implanted with God those
gods resided inside of him but during
the events of Darkseid war when Darkseid
was killed those gods
died and so what ended up happening is
new gods were put inside of his body
which is why it was given to us that
Shazam had a new host of abilities
because he had new gods given to him it
wasn't the traditional gods that we knew
now following that I think was Darkseid
war Shazam number one what is happening
after this is that we never saw him
again now one thing to keep in mind is a
Shazam has not had a solo series to
fight 1993 I think it was aside from the
new 52 run and that one was pretty
short-lived for the most part he just
appeared in other people's comic books
and that was really about it but the
fact remains with regards to where he is
there was an interview that Geoff Johns
did in May of 2016 I think it was and he
actually addressed a whole bunch of
journalists by this point I think it's
kind of common knowledge but the idea
was that he basically said the whole
purpose of DC rebirth was to go back
through and to essentially roll out
stories in a way when people weren't
getting them all at once and Shazam as
part of that Shazam is going to get his
own solo series that's actually going to
happen sometime I think next year or
maybe this year I Kevin burrow off top
my head but he's going to get his own
solo series he's going to go back to
being in the limelight and we're going
to find out what he's
doing everything that's been going on
presumably he's been learning about the
new powers that he has he's been
learning what his role is as a superhero
the biggest issue with this and one of
the reasons why a lot of fans express
frustration is because DC has played a
pretty close NIT in terms of continuity
which is to say there will be stories
where Batman will be fighting some
villain and the question will be okay
well where is Superman why don't you
call in Superman well Superman is off
doing this Superman is off doing that I
could call in the Justice League but the
Justice League is off doing this the
Justice League is off doing that Wonder
Woman's the exact same way the flash the
whole nine yards all the main members of
the Justice League and even other
superheroes that exist out there have
opportunities in their own solo stories
where they could call in their teammates
but they don't because they say well I
mean I want to handle this on my own
that's never happened with Shazam
there's never been a story that I'm
aware of so far where anybody's ever
said well why don't we call in Shazam
and somebody says well because she's and
off doing this he literally vanished if
there was no interview that indicated DC
wanted to do anything with him you would
have thought they just canceled his
character because nobody knows where he
is
now in terms of the the whole plan that
DC has when the new 52 first launched in
2011 for the most part it was a quick
rollout I mean it was just a ton of
books just being released by DC and the
reason was because it was built up with
such hype that people were just like
don't worry anything coming out of DC at
the time because it was also brand-new
Batman number one sold like gangbusters
Superman number one almost just flew off
the shelves with lightning speed it was
crazy how fast these stories were going
but what DC wanted to do with rebirth is
they wanted to take it slower what Geoff
Johns had basically said was that their
goal was to basically have have fans
focus on the characters more so than the
number of publications and so instead of
taking like the Marvel out and releasing
something like 50 or 60 comic books
instead DC's releasing about half of
those and they're playing it very very
slow they're doing slow bills they're
focusing on Batman and focusing on the
bat family they're focusing on Superman
they're focusing on the Superman family
they're introducing super Sons it's all
coming in ways but it's the idea that
they're just rolling this stuff out very
slowly and steadily Shazam is the exact
same way DC has plans for they are going
to bring them out the idea is that they
basically want to have a stage set for
by the time Shazam comes out DC wants
Superman Batman Wonder Woman all that
kind of stuff all those characters who
have already been set people already be
aware of who they are what they're about
that kind of a thing and then go into it
now the knee-jerk response to that
statement is well I mean is Batman
everybody already knows who Batman is
sure but if I walked around to the
general public and I showed them a
picture of Dick Grayson and Tim Drake
they wouldn't know who they are and so
the idea is to basically flesh those
characters out so that people do
understand who those characters are
people do understand the whole mythos
and everything so again that's really
the answer to the question at this point
right now Shazam is just waiting in the
wings we don't know what he's doing we
have no idea what he's been doing we
don't know if he's learning how to use
those powers we don't know if he's just
kind of hanging out playing pool at a
pub somewhere we have no clue what it is
that Shazam's doing all we know is that
he's just kind of there
we know he exists we know he's alive
because he's been featured before and
that's about it all the only other thing
that we know is that sometime in the
future DC will basically begin rolling
things out for his character and
bringing him into the fold in terms of
you know the greater DC landscape so
when a being said guys if I'm going to
be honest with you all in terms of my
opinion on what role I think she's an
will play I honestly think he'll have a
role in The Watchmen with the Watchmen
showing up I really hope it'll be this
situation where like the superheroes are
facing off against the Watchmen dr.
Manhattan so so forth and they're all
just kind of getting right you know and
when all hope seems lost all of a sudden
you just see this Shazam and then like
he just comes racing in you know one
saves the day like rescue Superman or
something along those lines I really
hope that's wouldn't that's what ends up
happening anyway guys want to go ahead
and get this video out there just want
to sort of answer this question as best
we could again at this point we don't
really know what's going on which is
Amelie I was going to get his own solo
series but we have no clue what he's
been doing there's no explanation in
terms of what he's doing at this moment
right now in DC rebirth we just know
he's there what would happen he said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]